her care here has been absolutely
amazing the doctors the nurses everyone
on the ward is just they're brilliant
considering what they're under
considering the shortages of Staff
considering the lack of resources
um and I think for me that's what's
really upsetting actually is because we
have a daughter with a life limiting a
lot of shortening condition and we have
some brilliant experts
um and they're being worked for the
bones
you know and actually the level of care
they provide is amazing but they're not
being able to provide it in the way they
want to provide it because the
resourcing is not there you know like I
said on Monday we reduce being
and the number of people coming through
the door is too many and it's not fair
to blame it on pandemic anymore is it
because actually we have problems in the
NHS before we went into the pandemic we
were short of doctors we were short of
feds going into the pandemic so I think
it's really wrong to blame it on the
pandemic and actually the damage that
you're doing to to families like myself
is terrible because it was Agony for us
as a family waiting for that call and
preparing our children
for that sister and her husband so then
for then it to be canceled and I know
you look and we're all numbers but
actually people waiting for kids
[Music]
and I think this problem with beds it's
a lot of it's the Health and Social care
isn't it we have people that can't get
into Health and Social care and are
taking up bread so until you as a
government prioritize card for social
care
we're not going to free up then they're
already limited number of beds and I
want to reiterate the staff at
absolutely incredible we're so lucky as
a nation to have this at nature